llama la atención que blinken viene de
Egipto donde resaltó el papel mediador
tanto de Washington como el del Cairo en
este conflicto entre Israel y los
territorios palestinos Cómo se forjó
este rol de mediación de estos gobiernos
en realidad Egipto es el único
estado árabe que se siente a negociar
con con Israel y desde los años 80
hacían los años 80 Estados Unidos lo
tiene como el interlocutor más válido
para Establecer un puente entre los
intereses de Estados Unidos en la región
y los Países Árabes que condicionan la
propia evolución del estado de Israel en
consecuencia todo todo pasa por el Cairo
bueno y vemos a blinken defendiendo como
es usual la solución de los dos estados
justo en un momento en que esa propuesta
tiene el menor apoyo en la historia
dentro de Israel y Jordania se puede
confiar en la vida diplomática o en
estas presiones internacionales
amigables para restaurar la estabilidad
en la región
no hay otra opción no hay
las otras dos opciones alternativas es
la desaparición de una de las partes los
Países Árabes y los sobre todo lo más
radicales no desean la existencia o
quieren la desaparición del estado de
Israel y los israelíes fundamentalmente
los colonos y la extrema derecha lo que
quieren es la desaparición de los
palestinos bien ninguna de esas dos
opciones es válida en el siglo XXI en
consecuencia no hay otra opción que la
que se llegó a Camp Davis en los años 90
de paz por territorios es decir que
Israel garantice la existencia y
reconozca la existencia de un estado
palestino que ceda un territorio
habitable y desarrollable para los
palestinos y al mismo tiempo que los
palestinos y el conjunto de los Países
Árabes vecinos reconozcan el estado de
Israel y juntos puedan vivir en paz y
desarrollarse en paz y escenas que
estamos haciendo que son terribles bueno
justamente usted ya lo estaba
mencionando y es a largo plazo que tan
viable es esta vía diplomática como
salida del conflicto ante esta cantidad
de ataques y provocaciones que vemos con
el pasar del tiempo
fundamentalmente Es que para los
radicales es muy sencillo torpedear los
los procesos de paz lo que se construye
con años con décadas de conversaciones
en un acto aislado como es el ataque a
la salida de una
de un templo israelí Pues en cuestión de
minutos desaparece esta confianza
desaparece estos estos adelantos hay que
apostar por la vía diplomática
fundamentalmente porque no hay otra las
otras es la desaparición de una de las
partes lo cual evidencia Hasta qué punto
podemos llegar a unas concepciones
totalitarias